hi everyone I'm Laura Ingram this is the
Ingram angle thanks so much for watching
us money can't buy him love that's the
focus of tonight's
angle happy International migrants day
now this is a big day for the Biden
Administration which is in the
deliberate process of remaking America
by facilitating the relocation of what
only 10 million people here and Counting
now the ultimate open borders Champion
Tony blinkin he released a statement
today actually bragging about their
record saying that the United States has
led the largest expansion in decades of
lawful migration Pathways to help
vulnerable migrants refugees and other
displaced
persons and they're not even trying to
hide the fact that this is just the
beginning of their efforts to resettle
America they want to promote inclusion
to expand ways for people to migrant
here and also globally now of course the
left refuses to see illegal immigration
as a problem despite what the polls have
consistently revealed Americans support
sane legal immigration not the travesty
of what we have now unless forced child
labor fueled by the open border is now
part of the Democrat platform the labor
department just found over 100 children
working for slaughter houses cleaning
slaughter houses in the middle of the
night this problem of Migrant children
particularly those from Guatemala
working inside us meat packing is really
pervasive and it's something that's now
caught the attention of federal
investigators as they try to really weed
out what employers might be taking
advantage of and how these children end
up here in the first
place congratulations to the Biden
Administration you must be so proud in
fact you are proud again these are the
inconvenient actual facts that Democrats
cannot defend against because the
conditions that they've created are
indefensible so all they're left with is
obsessing about the latest phrasing
Trump uses on the trail you know when
they let I think the real numbers 15 16
million people into our country when
they do that we got a lot of work to do
they're poisoning the blood of our
country that's what they've done
intellectual movement has begun to
burgeon on the far right it's a movement
that seeks to replace democracy remember
in 1939 in Madison Square Garden there's
an extraordinary Nazi reality so part of
what Trump has done he's tapped into a
longstanding illiberal tradition in the
United States and he's exploiting it
people say well why did did did Donald
Trump even read uh Hitler many many of
the recipients of his messages may not
have read Hitler but these things are
tried and true he's using a phrase that
immigrants are poisoning the blood of a
country and he's married to an
immigrant okay I just flipped on MSNBC
for five or 10 minutes and that's what I
saw today no joke now this is a good
time to remind people that CLA mcal was
actually a United States Senator he
married a migrant yeah that's what
Donald Trump's talking about all right
the disastrous effects of illegal
immigration they're all around us
Democrats can't justify any of it all
they can do is blather on about Trump's
Hitler or if Trump wins
he's never going to hold another
election it's all just absurd none of
it's persuasive none of it's working
again politicians May lie but numbers do
not Trump is leading in every major poll
by margins once thought impossible he's
up by four National in the latest Fox
poll and the New Monmouth University
poll Biden's approval ratings at a
dismal 34% that's another new low in
that survey meanwhile 54% of Democrats
want another Choice altogether
54% and proving again what a petty
oblivious man Biden is he's reportedly
blaming not himself not his policies for
these nightmarish numbers but his
campaign staff now after he pardoned the
Thanksgiving turkeys he acted like one
himself because according to the
Washington Post at a meeting with
campaign staff Biden delivered some
Stern words for the small group
assembled his poll numbers were
unacceptably low and wanted to know what
his team and his campaign were going to
do about it now the man still demands to
know what why his bomic speeches aren't
resonating because he complained that
his economic message had done little to
move the ball even as the economy was
growing and unemployment was
falling while these Anonymous sources
told the Washington Post that in the
head-to-head polling against Trump the
bidens have grown upset that they're not
making more progress how talk about out
of touch he apparently doesn't remember
the line that you can't put lipstick on
a pig that's actually a line Joe well
because we're in a giving mood it's the
season here at the angle we're going to
give Joe and Jill's entire cabinet a
handy list that explains why voters are
fleeing first real wages are down since
he took office and the cost of living
obscenely high for most voters of course
his foreign policy that's in a complete
shambles beginning with the Afghanistan
with withdrawal now the impending
embarrassment of Ukraine our so-called
allies we learn in Europe have been
freeloading and aren't kicking in any
more money which means they don't really
believe that Putin's an existential
threat more US money will only lead at
this point we all know to more death and
more
destruction and voters are also
recoiling in seeing Biden's woke aied
military which now has a catastrophic
collapse in
recruiting now this is shocking to know
no one except Joe Jill and maybe
secretary
Austin of course and again Biden's open
border has affected every part of our
country and the cities we know now are
imploding this is 100%
purposeful and Democrats do not see that
our citizens actually may be enraged to
hear that ungrateful migrants are
complaining about the free food they get
when their own families are struggling
to make ends
meat all right and if that's not enough
to turn off voters well they see the
sewer that Democrats have created on the
cultural front the trans Madness and the
BLM style focus in schools gay sex in
the Senate Dei and so much anti-Semitism
that they're now calling it the poison
ivy
league and if one thing is for
Clear Biden will not change course on
any of this on any major issue which
means no bargain on the border is worth
the paper it's written on forget it and
in their effort to beat Trump Democrats
do seem dedicated to two things number
one putting him in prison and number two
relentlessly attacking his supporters
you see the extremism of American
politics right now you see the
radicalization of so many of Donald
Trump's supporters they're fine with
imprisoning journalists they disagree
with so much for trying to win people
over
right yet even with all the all this the
plutocrats are going all in for Biden
he's outraising Republicans with gobs of
money coming from the fat cats in
Silicon Valley and of course in
Hollywood Wall Street Etc and then when
Obama came out and he said that Biden
could actually lose next year well well
well that is a signal to his billionaire
friends it's time to Pony up boys and
girls but even before Obama's warn
morning Biden was way ahead of
Republicans on the fundraising front
plus before Republicans are all giddy
about this Democrats do know how to turn
out the vote and they know how to stay
on message well I know what you're
saying but what message well so far it's
not Landing with people who see with
their own eyes what this team of
radicals has delivered and man it is an
ugly site now the Beatles Sayang Can't
Buy Me Love and Republicans better hope
Biden can't VI votes either and that's
the angle hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else